so I'm going to tell you a bit about
airflow kind of an introduction I'll
tell you what it does why you might use
it some things that are good to know
before jumping in and a little bit about
clover health we're a health insurance
company we use Python for literally
everything for our data operations to
our web applications to our data science
stack nothing but Python we're here in
San Francisco
one more stop down Bart by Paul Street
and we're hiring engineers and data
scientists where we have a booth over in
the other room and you can come talk to
me come talk to a couple of our data
scientists or hanging out there um I'm
on the data platform engineering team at
clover and I feel a little bit like a
plumber because I just mostly moved data
from one place to another like a porter
I need a wheelbarrow I've been using
kind of scientific Python since around
2008 when I got a job at NASA Goddard
Space Flight Center it started using
Python to make images from satellite
data and plots and I go by jiffy Club on
the internet because Matt Davis was
taken and so if you're looking for me
don't try matt davis it won't work um so
it's kind of the outline here and give
you the very brief history of airflow
and talked about what it's useful for
give you a brief tour of its user
interface then talk about what it's like
to put it in production and deploying it
and about how you go about putting
together a pipeline in our flow and then
some useful things you should know so
where did it all come from and it came
out of Airbnb last year built by someone
who worked on similar infrastructure at
Facebook on their data swarm application
and his name's max this year and airflow
joined the Apache program in their in
their incubator so I think we can kind
of expect to see airflow around for a
long time if that goes well and if it
officially joins Apache
so what do you use airflow for so a
pretty common thing that people need to
do is on some sort of schedule they want
the thing to happen a common thing is
taking some data working on it and then
putting it back out there in some new
and polished form but it could be
anything and airflow is kind of like the
alarm clock in this diagram it's the
thing that says it is now time to run a
task and sends those things off to do
stuff there are other things that do
this there's another python-based thing
called Luigi and there are some JVM
based things airflow is the only one
that I have any experience with and so
which is why I'm talking about it so if
if airflow is the alarm clock here the
rest of this is you you're building a
pipeline of things you want done and
pipelines in air flow are a series of
tasks connected by dependencies so you
want one task to run before others and
and I like to call them pipelines
because I think that's a more sensible
and intuitive name but in air flow world
they're called DAGs or directed acyclic
graphs because you're not allowed to
have cyclical dependencies between tasks
because then your pipelines would never
finish so air flow is really upfront
about that and so one of the nice things
about this though is if you layout your
pipeline air flow can be like okay I
need to run these things before I can on
these other things but those first two
tasks are independent they can run at
the same time so you get some
parallelization if you can lay out your
your tasks like this so what can those
little tasks do anything really I'm only
being a little facetious because you can
run arbitrary Python as tasks and we all
know you can use Python for anything but
there are built-in operators and
for operators the airflow term for these
individual tasks so when you want to
create a task you create an instance of
something called an operator that has a
certain interface you can make your own
but they come with a bunch of built-in
ones so one for calling Python things
one for shelling out to bash and running
sequel things hive they're more you can
make your own um so especially with the
easy integration with Python like sky's
the limit you can really do anything you
want and we use it for running sequel
things a lot a lot of sequel queries or
shifting data from SFTP to s3 but you
can use it for sending email like
running your periodic email sending
thing on whatever you need it to do so
I'm going to give you a couple of
examples of real pipelines that we have
at Clover this is one entire pipeline
they don't have to be fancy it can be
one task that you want to run on a
schedule no problem you can get a little
more fancy so there's a few things we
want done and then it branches out and
those are those things at the end can
run in parallel and a failure on the
left side of this would prevent
everything from running downstream of it
but a failure here a failure on that
upper branch doesn't affect the lower
branch that stuff will still finish if
we can so another nice thing about your
flow and having laid out your tasks in
these independent Forks of a pipeline or
maybe even at different pipelines is is
some independence there those things run
separately and you can get all the way
through one part of your pipeline and
get as much done as you can even if one
part of it failed and then there's this
this is our biggest pipeline you can't
even see it there on the right and
because there are so many tasks we're
going on like five hundred tasks and
this and you can tell that the layout
like the the interdependency is pretty
complicated
there's another view of it there on the
left and you can't tell but those are
arrows on the left's of showing
dependency um a few hours all the time
that the first thing we do to new people
is usually make them debug things it's a
little rough no it's not bad we support
them um okay so air flow comes with an
interface and that's how I got those
screenshots so showing you and this is
actually one of the really nice things
about it in addition to the fact that it
runs the things you tell it to run gives
you this nice interface for figuring out
what's going on and knowing what's going
on at any given time so the default view
is um kind of like your pipeline status
so this is a list of all not all of our
pipelines but some of our pipelines the
name over on the left it's that you can
turn them on and off and the red blocks
in the middle and your schedule means
that ones running right now and and then
the statuses show you how many tasks was
completed in the dark green the light
green is how many tasks are running
right now you can see if tasks failed
the red circles and then these links on
the right are out to different views
about that pipeline so this is one
potential view for a pipeline the Gantt
chart I love this because it lets you
see very quickly in what order tasks ran
how long they took so it's very easy to
tell which task is taking a long time
here and across the top there you can
see links over to some of the other
views you can see the graph view those
were the screenshots I was showing you
earlier and the task duration is a
historical graph showing you how long
into
we'll task to take in in the past which
is useful for seeing how long are like
how your tasks are scaling maybe as
you've added data over time see how your
tasks are handling that and scaling up
with that and it's really useful if
you're like wow my pipeline took twice
as long last night like what happened
you can go to these views and be like
which task was responsible for that and
sometimes it's just one task that you
need to debug and find out what was
going on so thanks to these graphs
pretty quick to find those things and
then you can drill into task details um
the bottom things here are actually ways
to kind of manually tell air flow to do
things you can clear out like history
about this run or you can sometimes be
useful if you want to trigger a rerun so
you make air flow forget that it ran
these things by like clearing downstream
tasks like the tasks and everything
downstream of it and then it'll be like
oh I haven't run this yet and rerun it
for you
which is useful sometimes and then you
can under task details you can see all
the configuration for that task you've
defined that in code but this is the
quickest way to go see it most of the
time rendered lets you see the actual
code some specially this is nice if it
was a parameterised sequel or bash like
it will render the actual sequel query
that ran or the actual bash command that
ran and then that log button also very
useful and we store all of the task logs
on s3 so when you click that button
airflow pulls them from s3 and shows
them to you but again like when a task
fails and you want to know why you go
click that button and look at the logs
hopefully you've written good logs um
but even if you're sending logs out to
kind of a traditional logging stock like
elasticsearch in Cabana this is still
much faster way to find the logs
specific to a single task really handy
and that's it for the tour of the UI and
those very quick the airflow
documentation has a more complete tour
which you can check out so what does
airflow actually look like when you put
it in production what are the components
of it what do you need running the first
thing you need is a database a sequel
database so my sequel or Postgres are
good things this is where air flow
stores all of the information about what
things have run in the past how long did
they take what's running right now and
so on that kind of fills in all of those
views I was just showing you so like
that plot of how long tasks took in the
past as you know it's calling out to the
database and being asking like okay give
me all of the most recent 50 runs of
this pipeline all of the tasks in it and
how long they took them in it turns it
into a plot and so this needs to be kind
of a permanent stable database backing
your thing that you don't want data
disappearing from the next thing is a
web server that's obviously what's
showing you all of those things I was
just showing you and it's a flask
application pretty straightforward and
but you need to run this on some
computer where I can talk to the
metadata TV the scheduler is a Python
process that decides what to run when so
nothing pretty much nothing runs unless
you have started the scheduler and it
goes current crawls the filesystem and
looks for like it's importing Python
files out of us out of a directory you
can figure looking for DAGs loading up
all of those DAGs looking at their
configuration and then figuring out one
need to run and actually putting tasks
out there to run on the queue so if you
if you have a worker queue the scheduler
is the one kind of putting those things
on the queue and or they're kind of I'll
talk in a second about kind of
the other ways the scheduler cannot but
the scheduler is what is actually
deciding what to run when so a pretty
important thing and and then the final
component you need are computers running
the things that you want to run the
workers in kind of the full-fledged
distributed computing kind of version of
this and the recommended engine is
celery which has been around in Python
for a long time for doing distributed
task queues with Python and so it's kind
of yet another component of this so and
you have to have a celery queue task
queue which is usually RabbitMQ or Redis
so if it's Redis that's another database
you need if it's RabbitMQ those are you
have to start rabbitmq servers on the
scheduler and on the individual workers
and then on top of that you have to
start celery workers there's an airflow
kind of shortcut for this and are
through the airflow CLI to start up the
individual workers they don't
necessarily have to be on different
computers they can all be these could
all be on the same computer but you have
to keep in mind that the workers are
going to be doing work and depending on
what that work is they may have
different requirements than the
scheduler in the web server the
scheduler and the web server are pretty
lightweight processes they don't do a
whole lot of actual computing but your
workers may need to be me fee depending
what they're doing they may only be
sending commands out to other database
things and in which case they can be
very lightweight as well it just depends
and an alternative is to instead of
using celery there are other executor 'z
which are the kind of tasks they're kind
of the components of airflow that is
actually executing the tasks and so
there are ones to run them locally on
the same machine as the scheduler which
can save you the headache of dealing
with celery and distributed computing
it's a
little bit simpler but it also means
your scheduler and workers are more
tightly coupled so for example
restarting if you needed to restart the
scheduler it's also going to kill all of
the tasks turning on that machine at the
same time so it's it's a bit simple
simpler operationally and but there are
trade-offs there I'll talk a little bit
more about that in the future but that's
kind of the basics of air flow you need
the metadata to be the server the
scheduler you need some workers and if
you're using distributed workers you
need some way for jobs to get from the
scheduler outs of those workers like
celery excuse me so time for some code
what is it like to actually build a
pipeline it starts with the dag so you
instantiate something called the dag you
give it a name the ID that needs to be
unique among all of your DAGs that air
flow is going to get import you give it
a start date this is for us most of the
time when we put a one we put something
into production we give it a date of
like today or tomorrow so that it starts
running as soon as we put it in
production but if you put it in the past
air flow we'll backfill all the way back
to that start date so it's going to look
at the schedule interval and figure out
how many times it should have run going
back to that start date and actually run
all of those so if there's something
that you want run on a cadence the where
it's like working on a time interval or
something and you wanted that going back
to some date like when you started
importing a certain data source you can
do that in air flow will start from the
beginning and run all the way up through
the present and in that scheduled
interval here it's a cron expression
there are a couple of simple shortcuts
for like daily and hourly and but you
can also do kind of a complicated cron
expression and air flow we'll figure
that out it's a question
that's up to you
um airflow through a air flow makes
available to you the execution date of
I'll explain the execution date in a
little bit but it makes available to
your tasks the date at which it's
pretending to run kind of and so it's up
to your tasks to take that execution
date figure out when and figure out what
time period it's supposed to be
operating on and make use of that so for
example if you're working on selecting
like a time series out of a database you
wouldn't use like date time now you
would look at the date airflow is
telling you that it's running four and
figure out what data to select based on
that the schedule interval can be
anything cron can run but you don't want
to go to fine-grained air flow only
kicks off tasks every minute or 30
seconds or something so you you kind of
it it's not really meant to do like
sub-second or you know second or minute
going down to largest fractions of an
hour I think is probably the most
recommended level to go with these you
can also put that start date in the
future if you didn't want it running and
it would sit there and wait until that
time came and then I would start so a
couple of useful dag arguments that I
didn't talk about their default args
these are not arguments to the dag
itself their arguments to the tasks
you're going to put in the dag and so if
you have a bunch of ones that are in
common across all the tasks it's useful
to collect them into this default argus
dictionary and feed them here to the
pipeline and then the pipeline will make
sure that those settings are applied to
all of the tasks that you add to it um
max active runs tells air flow how many
runs of the entire pipeline should be
running concurrently so you can imagine
if you had a daily task
that you wonder you put the start date
30 days in the past that's 30 days of
pipeline that air flow could start
running immediately as soon as you put
that in production you may not want 30
of them hitting your database all at the
same time or going out of workers all at
the same time there's a global setting
of how many dogs can run at the same
time that you can set for air flow but
then you can set it independently for
individual pipelines so a lot of
clover's pipelines have this set to one
because a lot of our pipelines do
destructive things to the databases and
we don't want more than one of them
doing that at a time so that's a way to
kind of keep that from happening and
then if there are errors in the pipeline
and it takes longer than expected to
kind of resolve that and stuff you don't
get the next one kicking off before
you've got fixes in place things like
that and finally concurrency limits how
many tasks within the pipeline can run
at the same time and this is especially
useful for something like that really
complicated pipeline I showed you where
potentially dozens of those tasks can be
eligible to be run at the same time that
could like take over our entire worker
pool and prevent anything else from
running at the same time so we limit
that to a few at a time we we actually
don't use it using this concurrency
parameter because I don't think this was
an option when we started using air flow
but it would be a good way to go now so
a question to do retries mmm yeah so the
question was if there are errors in the
task can you retry them and the answer
is yep it's a little bit complicated and
I'll talk more about code deployment
later but you can ship new code to the
tip to the workers and then say please
run this one again and if everything is
hunky-dory it'll pick up that new code
and run the task with the new code and
then the pipeline can progress
yeah Oh two hours and it hasn't finished
by then maybe yeah and so the question
was can you put timeouts on things you
can put timeouts both at the pipeline
level and the individual tasks level um
so this is a coding up tasks or
importing the operators module and
making a Python operator the task ID has
to be unique within the pipeline and you
have to pass in the dag here to the
operator so that it gets associated with
the right pipeline and then depending on
the task you're telling it what things
what to run so here we're pointing it at
a function if this was a sequel task we
could put a string there that was a
sequel like had sequel commands we could
point it at a file that had sequel
commands in it both of those work same
with bash so the magic happens when you
start when you make more tasks so here
we make a second one it's also Python
pointed at a different function but then
we do second task set upstream first
task and now we have dependency the
second task cannot run until first task
is completed and so you can put together
as many of these as you want you can do
set upstream you can use that downstream
like this is how you build up a pipeline
with tasks that can run concurrently or
have to run in some dependency order you
have to do it programmatically but I
will sort of circle back to that so
useful task arguments retries if a task
if it's safe to retry a task you can
tell it to do that so we have certain
tasks where
I'll get blocked by kind of database
access issues and we want to wait five
seconds and try again so you can set the
retry and the retry like the wait before
a retry and pool is a way of limiting
how many of that task can run at the
same time so pool is an airflow concept
where you you say I'm making a pool with
ten workers in it and then you assign
workers to that pool and every time a
worker runs it takes a slot out of that
pool so only ten of them can run at this
up to ten of them can run at the same
time and so for I was talking about that
concurrency parameter earlier pools are
actually how we are limiting concurrency
right now is by assigning workers to
specific pools that only have so many
slots in them so that they're they're
not taking over the whole suite of
workers queue is a celery option where
you can assign tasks to specific celery
cues where you then start a worker
listening on that queue and that's a way
to assign tasks to specific workers and
this could be useful when you have
workers that are co-located with data
workers that are really computationally
beefy in order to do computational tasks
and other workers that are not as beefy
because all they do is is send commands
onto a database for example where you
want to differentiate where tasks run
use use that there's the actually huge
intime out to put a time limit on it
trigger rule is the rule for which the
task gets executed um so the default is
all upstream tasks were successful but
you can change that to things like all
upstream tasks failed or all upstream
tasks are done which is like they've
been run and ended in any state for
example so you can get creative you can
pass in so in my examples these
functions as written these Python
functions would have to take no
arguments because they're not going to
get called with any arguments um but you
can set up a dictionary or list of
arguments to pass in there to your
functions
there's one I forgot here called context
which is a dictionary that airflow
provides that have a bunch of
information about the task and like the
running environment that's how you would
get a hold of something like the
execution date like what date airflow
thinks it's running under and you can
set environment variables for bash tasks
you can air flow has a system that I'm
not going to describe in detail but
doing Jinja templating on your tasks so
like if you have sequel or bash a way of
inserting data into those or parameters
into those using Jinja templates so you
can provide variables that will be
available inside the Jinja templating so
this gets to the question earlier about
building more complicated pipelines you
have to use code to write pipelines but
you can get creative about it because
it's Python and so if you have a series
of files that you want to parse for
example you can write a loop and create
a task for every one of those files and
you may or may not tie them to some
upstream task that you want run first
but now you've got however many tasks is
you have files and they can all run in
parallel you can let air flow schedule
those for building that really giant
pipeline that I showed you earlier with
500 things in it nobody wanted to code
up 500 things and least of all me most
of those tasks are in fact all of those
tasks are either bash shell files or
sequel files so we developed a system
where people can write a yamo file that
contains the task dependency and the
name of the file that needs to be run as
part of the task and when that die gets
constructed it starts from some root
directory crawls all of the
subdirectories finds those yamo files
turns them into air flow tasks and
connects them up in dependency order
so you can do things like that to get
around having to code up individually
however many tasks you need we do the
same for parsing files we have you know
we crawl like SFTP director file things
and like pick out files and again
there's like we do a lot of Gamal
configuration stuff where like we put
you know configurations in a directory
and those get turned into tasks ok so
now for some things that are nice enough
about our flow and one is the executor
types I already talked about this a
little bit executor --zz are the things
the in charge of actually running your
tasks and keeping track of them we use
the celery executor so we run celery in
addition to airflow and it has a task
queue air Flo puts tasks on those queues
and then the workers pick them up and
then send signals back about being done
or heartbeats and so on and so it's
really relying on celery there for that
part of it and the sequential executor
is has tasked run in the same process as
the scheduler so you'll run it and the
scheduler will actually stop scheduling
things because it ran a task and it's
waiting for it to finish and that's not
very useful in production but it's
useful for debugging I'll show you the
local executor also runs on the same
machine as the scheduler but it uses
multi processing pythons multi
processing module to run the tasks in a
different process so the scheduler can
go on doing its thing and there
according to blog posts I've read about
air flow at other companies people are
using this local executor in production
because they kind of want the simplicity
of not having a distributed worker queue
and they've made that work for them um
right so there would be some challenges
around that in terms of like it that
doesn't work for us because we have a
lot of long running tasks and we want to
be able to do maintenance on
individual workers or the scheduler
without necessarily shutting down any
tasks that are running because it would
be expensive to have to start them over
so the like the distributive model works
better for us but if you're if all of
your tasks like if you don't mind
restarting tasks or or if you're only
running air flow for part of the day for
example we run air flow 24/7 so that
also kind of makes it challenging to
deploy good but if there's like part of
the day when you're running in part of
the day when you can put a new code or
something like that the local executor
can be an option like people are using
that in production and then I don't know
much about the Mesa executor and I we
don't use mesas but if you already have
like a meso s-- system and like cluster
setup like there's a community
contributed option for running your
tasks on that there's a little tip for
local debugging so with options like
celery or multi-processing
when you want to set a breakpoint in
your code it's not going to work because
the process that you use to start Python
is not the same one in which the
debugger gets invoked so the sequential
executor is a way around that you use
the sequential executor and you can put
in port PDB and put a stripe a
breakpoint in your code and then use the
airflow CLI the command line interface
to air flow and the command line
interface air flow is how you it has a
lot of things and it can do most of the
things the scheduler does and I haven't
gone into any detail about it and
because you can read about it on their
website but it has web server commands
and a scheduler command and a worker
command and so on but my favorite
utility is airflow test where you give
it a tag name and a task name in an
execution date and it runs that task for
you without putting any of the
information like it doesn't care about
upstream tasks it doesn't care about
downstream tasks it's only going to run
that one task it's not going to put any
information in the database but it'll
still print out the logs if that's what
you want
and if you use the sequential executor
it'll be in the same process as the one
that gets started when you're on air
flow test so set trace will work so this
is really useful for debugging when
you're when you're setting these up
locally another tip for pipeline testing
when you're developing a pipeline
locally so in clover we all like
everybody who works on the pipeline's
gets air flow running locally they have
a post grass running locally so that
they have the metadata to be and you
know to actually develop and test
pipelines they'll want to run them
locally and so when I'm working on a
pipeline locally and I want to run the
entire pipeline I'll put the start date
some date in the past so that air flow
wants to run it
I'll give it a schedule integral of once
so that it only tries to run once and
then I'll run it as far as it gets
check the output check the logs if there
are exceptions so on all through the
interface and then when I like make
changes and want to rerun it I can shut
things down now just restarting the
scheduler won't do that because the
record of the dag having run is still in
the database and air flow will see that
and not try to rerun anything but you
can go through the UI and delete those
records from the database and then air
flow won't know that it has run it in
the past and it'll try again but using
that the once flag is useful because
then it doesn't matter how long in the
past the start date was air flow won't
try to do any backfilling it's only
going to run at once like that means
once ever sandy this is one thing we
have a lot of fun with is air flow time
the and this is the execution date I'm
talking about so the execution date is
something provided to tasks through air
flows kind of context thing and it part
of that is the execution date because
you want to know at what was the planned
date at which this ran but air flow
doesn't actually tell you the date the
the task started it tells you the date
of the previous when the previous task
started so a task starting at three
o'clock in the afternoon today will have
an execution date of 3 a.m. this morning
so it's like covering that interval um
so this is the thing to keep to remember
is really confusing and it bugs us all
the time and something you have to keep
in mind if you're making use of the
execution date in your pipeline um it's
kind of general advice make sure that
your business logic is separate from
building air flow pipelines I'm working
on a project right now that's going to
be an air flow pipeline and I haven't
even imported air flow into the project
yet I built a CLI into it so I can run
it locally and test it and stuff because
adding air flow on top of that is a
whole other layer of things you want to
debug and you want to know that your
your business logic is solid before you
start trying to integrate that with air
flow because that's going to be a whole
other layer of things you need to work
with so I reckon being able to run and
test code without involving air flow at
all deploying new codes workers is
challenging because the long running
Python processes both the worker like
celery workers and the scheduler a long
running Python processes and even if you
we have cron processes running on those
same machines that are doing get polls
every few minutes to retrieve the
freshest version of the code but those
won't get imported because Python
doesn't import things twice right it
imports them once and then they're kind
of globally cached so the next time some
code needs that thing it just comes out
of that cache so you need to restart the
processes every so often so that they
pick up the new code you're shipping and
we've landed on two things for that for
the scheduler it has this num runs flag
that makes the scheduler abort itself
after having done so many cycles of like
coughs and dag imports I think we
probably set this to 1 because we want
it to to restart like every time it does
this so that it's very fast at picking
up code changes this means you have to
have something restarting it we have a
little script that's running an infinite
bash loop around this but you could also
use something like a supervisor to do
the same thing and then on the worker
side if you're using celery there's this
option celery D masks tasks per child
that causes celery to restart workers
after having run so many tasks and again
we set this to one so that every time a
worker starts up it's in a new process
and is going to pick up the latest code
okay so and wrapping up here so having
learned all that why did we actually
choose airflow it's written in Python
and that's a big deal for us because we
use Python for everything internally and
it came down to so your only options if
you're using Python are pretty much air
flow or Luigi air flows UI is really
useful um so we like that the
programmatic pipeline construction is
the big one
Luigi's pipeline construction involves
sub classing to create tasks and that's
much harder to do kind of in a loop for
example so airflow one there and just
the fact that it Luigi would be fine
here also like complex pipelines are no
problem for Luigi either but we knew we
were going to have complex pipelines
and we had confidence that our flow
could handle them ok so these are some
links airflow documentation clovers
websites and my info here and that's it
any questions
it's one that the tops that anything
from yeah yeah so the question is about
passing things from one task to another
you can there's something called XCOM or
trot like cross communication so you can
have things passed from one task to
another but they have to be essentially
strings like very simple things tokens
so you can pass back a file name or
something like that you cannot pass
something like a data frame yep so so
you have to put it you have to put it
somewhere you have to move it to s3 you
have to put it in a new table in the
database something like that yeah and
yeah so the question was how do we deal
with dependencies I know some Python
dependencies mm-hmm yeah um you have to
have deployment for that um we use
docker things because we have to um
because of our hosting provider uses
doctor so we have dr. things that
install all of whatever we need you know
but it's very classic Python require you
know pip install - our requirements that
txt in a doctor image and then the
processes start up in those docker
images by our fire host
you you could use the celery cues to do
that but our worker pool is the same so
that it doesn't matter yeah um
potentially you know like if the Redis
thing like if the Redis holding the the
celery cube failed like you can't talk
to workers anymore if our our hosting
provider it can be a little interesting
like if they go down like everything's
over
it is pretty fault tolerance in terms of
like like the scheduler is pretty good
like we haven't had a lot of it has some
interesting quirks but like it doesn't
totally fail it can do things like we've
seen things like two tasks getting
picked up on different workers and like
competing with each other sometimes we
don't know whether that's airflow or
celery's fault or both or you know some
interplay yeah
it's not the task it's the the
scheduling rate and I would say a few
minutes like you like less than five
minutes would be probably not a good
idea and I would recommend even more
like fifteen or thirty no no the
scheduling interval an individual tasks
can be instant and it's fine yeah that's
fine yeah it really the the amount of
time a task takes to execute I don't
think has any effects on airflow at all
there oh yeah yeah there's there's
absolutely a delay between when the task
finishes and when airflow picks up that
it has finished but hopefully there's
not like like if you're trying to do
sub-second coordination between tasks
and airflow airflow is not the right
tool
yes um rarely like will have this
problem with um sort of like we'll have
this problem with tasks so the question
was about like do you ever see things
like tasks getting lost or tasks getting
into a bad state we do see things where
tasks will be marked failed but appear
to be still running but when we check on
a box are still running or the opposite
where like air flow will think a task is
running but when we go look on the box
there's nothing going on so there's some
like community like celery communication
miscommunication there we sometimes see
like logs disappear especially when
they're retries and so like the first
tries logs will disappear when the
second try of the task happens which is
something like I really want to fix that
but there is some interesting stuff that
can happen and back
and that's something we're very
interested in - so the question was like
does does airflow help you at all with
like lineage of your data the answer is
no we're very interested in that as well
but it's something we're going to have
to tackle ourselves the dependency graph
is there like the task dependency graph
but beyond that no help from airflow
okay I think lunch is outside probably -
announcement slice is outside